we're gonna begin with this president
Trump spending much of his second day in
Britain with the Prime Minister who's
about to lose her job her last day by
the way is Friday the president and
Teresa Maher discussing a wide range of
topics including climate change trade
and brexit a short distance away
thousands of protesters gathered to
demonstrate against President Trump they
are now marching toward the site of the
meeting the president's state visit
began with a full day of events
involving Britain's royal family ending
with a white tie banquet hosted by Queen
Elizabeth Paula Reid is outside the
Prime Minister's residence at 10 Downing
Street in London where Mae and the
president are meeting right now Paula
what can we expect from day two of the
president's trip well Anthony day two
shifts from royal pageantry to politics
and a short time ago the President and
the First Lady arrived here at 10
Downing Street they were greeted by the
Prime Minister and her husband and I
sure didn't side for a working lunch
surrounded by US and British business
leaders President Trump and Prime
Minister Theresa May emphasised their
country's economic ties it's a great
project but I think it's a partnership
that we can take even further
president Trump expressed optimism about
a new trade deal once the UK formally
exits the European Union I don't know
exactly what your timing is but stick
around let's do this deal with her
Friday departure looming May is
considered a lame-duck by the White
House officials insist it's in times of
political uncertainty that the two
countries must stand together the trip
also provides a welcome distraction from
impeachment talk back home
last night President Trump was treated
to a glittering state banquet a scripted
mr. Trump thanked the Queen for her
hospitality and the UK's friendship as
we honor our shared victory in heritage
we affirm the common values that will
unite as long into the future as the
first family dined with the Royals
including the Duke and Duchess of
Cambridge the Queen reflected on the two
countries long-standing alliance the
anniversary of d-day reminds us all that
our countries have achieved together the
Queen stressed the importance of
international alliances to a president
who has repeatedly rebuffed them Britain
and the United States worked with other
allies to build an assembly of
international institutions to ensure
that the horrors of conflict would never
be repeated the banquet capped a day of
royal pomp and ceremony president Trump
appeared to make a concerted effort to
observe royal protocol walking behind
the Queen and paying respects to his
host following this lunch the Prime
Minister and the president are expected
to hold a joint press conference after
that event the president and the first
lady will get a tour of the Churchill
war rooms and later tonight they have
some additional social engagements with
Prince Charles and his wife Camilla
Paula we're seeing protests in London
happening right now in fact what can we
expect on that front today Tony we can
actually hear several thousand
protesters demonstrating not far from
here but we're told it's a considerably
smaller group than what was expected
among those protesters is opposition
leader Jeremy Corbyn he boycotted last
night state banquets but he is expected
to address the demonstrations now one of
the groups is employing a large balloon
depicting President Trump as a giant
orange baby in a diaper clutching an
iPhone the organizer says the balloon is
meant to send a message to President
Trump that he is not welcome here Paula
Reid in London 4's Paula thank you who
could forget the balloon I think they
had it last year as well